The woman fell to the ground,
clutching her ankle in pain. It
had crunched badly as she'd fallen,
and now, as she looked down at it,
she could see that it was bent totally out of
shape. The heavy metal collar choking her neck
made it difficult for her to catch her breath
as she tried her best not to hyperventilate.
The rain was hammering down so ferociously
that she could barely see more than 20 feet
in any direction. But she didn't need to see
far to know how deadly of a predicament she
had found herself in. She cried out at the top
of her voice for someone to come and find her,
anyone, but the only sound that filled
her ears was the wild howling of the
wind and the steady hammering of
water into the bog all around her.
She would get hypothermia and die. No, wait, she
couldn’t, could she? She knew she couldn't die,
but she also knew that she was still capable
of suffering. Just how bad would it feel to
be in the clutches of hypothermia with
a broken ankle and know that no matter
how bad the pain and suffering got, she
would never feel the release of death?
She closed her eyes, trying her best
not to think of the worst possibilities,
just as the sound of gunfire
erupted in the nearby buffer.
She cried out again, holding both hands up in
the air, doing the best she could around the
heavy metal collar, but no one shouted out in
reply. There was a pause in the gunfire. Maybe
they'd heard her. Maybe they were trying to
figure out a way to come down and rescue her.
CRACK!
A bullet split open a rotten
tree trunk just a few feet to
her right. The woman threw her hands
over her head and cowered in the dirt,
feeling the metal of her collar digging
into her skin tighter than ever.
Please don’t let it happen again,
she prayed silently into the dirt.
Encased in the collar around her neck were 4.5kg
of plastic explosives, each with a fragmentation
layer pointed inwards towards her neck and head.
With just the push of a button, they could...
She didn't want to think about it. All she knew
was that she couldn't let
that happen to her again.
Looking through eyes bloodied with tears and
rain, she saw lying in the dirt just a few
feet away from her that infernal machine
that was the sorry cause of all of this.
*
The SCP Foundation has long stood
as a bastion of hope, information,
and security for the entirety of the human
race. I'm sure you are well aware of the number
of world-destroying catastrophes that have been
averted by the hardworking researchers, agents,
and other members of the Foundation—all without
the general public having the slightest clue
that something was amiss. With state-of-the-art
holding cells all over the globe and the sharpest
minds humanity has ever produced working around
the clock to ensure the protection of humanity,
it is hard to imagine an entity that
should not be contained by such a group.
And yet one such entity does exist—SCP-001.
You may have come across the O5 Council by this
point. While the SCP Foundation operates beyond
the world’s jurisdiction, the O5 Council operates
beyond the Foundation's jurisdiction. The rules,
methods, and protocols that are the
cornerstone of securing, containing,
and protecting countless entities
around the world sometimes cannot be
applied. Certain entities require us
to temporarily abandon our humanity,
abandon our sense of order, and step
briefly into chaos… for the greater good.
I'm telling you all of this because SCP-001 is not
held in a containment cell. There are no keypads,
locked doors, observation windows, or
health and safety forms. SCP-001 is
not confined to a specific territory or
even a specific country. For some SCPs,
this is a practical necessity—serpents that are
hundreds of kilometers long swimming through
the depths of the ocean, for example. But for
SCP-001, it serves a more… psychological purpose.
*
The Scottish Highlands are the most remote
part of the United Kingdom. Out there,
you can walk for miles and miles without seeing a
single soul. Open countryside, mountains, lochs,
and forests surround you in all directions. The
weather is harsh and unrelenting, the walking
even more so. On a regular basis, walkers fall
and break their legs, but without phone service
or anyone else nearby to come and help, they can
quickly disappear into the wilderness forever.
The peat bogs of Scotland used to see human
sacrifices in early settlements. Afraid of the
ghosts and spirits that haunted the bogs, people
would throw their family members into the deepest
parts and watch them drown, hoping that whatever
was lurking beneath wouldn't come and find them.
So as the group of soldiers crested
the top of the mountain and looked
down beneath them to the eerie peat bogs
obscured by mist and constant rainfall,
you would forgive a shiver running up
their spines. But, of course, it didn't.
That was because this group of soldiers were quite
unlike any others that humanity has ever produced.
All were nameless. None of them existed on any
government databases, on any Foundation databases,
or even on the databases of the O5 Council itself.
Their individual backgrounds, nationalities,
and families were totally unknown to
everyone other than themselves. Some
had been tortured for years, others had been the
torturers. The thing that united them, however,
was their inhuman ruthlessness—a squad of eight
soldiers utterly devoid of any sense of empathy.
What could they possibly have to be
afraid of in the peat bogs when they
themselves were the evil ghosts walking through?
But then, one person was afraid—a
shiver ran up her spine as she
looked over the edge and down into
the murky black and green below.
SCP-001-1.
Around her neck was the bomb collar. Each
of the eight soldiers surrounding her had
a button mounted on a watch on the
back of their wrists. At any moment,
any one of them could hit the button, and
all four and a half kilograms of plastic
explosives would go off, sending
her on an express trip to oblivion.
Aside from the collar, she wore a plain white
dress made of cotton. It was muddy and torn
apart at the hem from days of walking through the
Scottish wilderness. When she had first arrived,
she had begged those around her to supply her with
some warm clothes, something practical that would
keep her comfortable and stave off any illness.
Her requests, however, had not been acknowledged.
Clutched in her trembling, outstretched
hands was the Machine. SCP-001-A. From
its external appearance, you would think
it was nothing more than a wooden box—a
perfect cuboid made from glossy
dark wood. There were no symbols,
no seams, no latches—nothing to
indicate any method of operation.
When the woman and the machine had first been
delivered into the hands of the O5 Council,
the researchers had spent weeks and millions
of dollars trying to activate the Machine.
Their best scientists had scanned for
every possible form of radiation and
tried every method they could conceive
to stimulate the box into opening.
The ultimate failed attempt involved traveling
to North Korea, where they negotiated placing
the box 20 centimeters beneath a small
nuclear warhead in return for granting
the dictatorship key information
on how to construct such a weapon.
As we have established, the O5 Council
operates beyond any kind of jurisdiction.
Yet, at the bottom of the irradiated
crater, sat a perfectly intact wooden
box that was cool to the touch and
showed no signs of radioactivity.
Only one person could interact with the box and
unearth the secrets that were inside—SCP-001-1,
the woman who stood trembling
on the side of the mountain.
A gun jabbed her in the back, forcing her to
continue moving. She asked the soldiers around
her how much longer they had to walk that day,
but none of them replied. They never did. In the
six years that she had been held hostage by
this tiny militia, she had never once heard
any of them say a word, not even to each other.
Perhaps it was this telepathic understanding that
seemed to run between them that unnerved her the
most. Despite having never spoken to each other,
each soldier seemed to understand the
others intimately, and she had no doubt
that any one of the eight would press the
button on their wrist at a moment's notice.
Sadly for her, she knew this from experience.
The incident had happened four years ago now,
as the group was traveling through Patagonia.
It was a day almost identical to the one she
was having now. They had been transported by
a helicopter flown by one of the eight into
the middle of the wilderness. There, they had
marched for days without saying a single word.
Exhaustion had overtaken her legs, and she
stumbled to the ground. Unfortunately for her,
this happened slightly too close to
the female soldier in front of her.
Her knees hadn't even hit the ground before the
blast went off. The woman didn't remember it,
of course—how could she? In an instant, her
mind had been utterly destroyed. What she
did remember was the next 18 months
as her body slowly healed itself,
one brain cell at a time. It wasn't so
much like waking up from a nightmare;
it was more constructing a nightmare slowly,
alongside your consciousness as neuron by neuron
your brain reformed itself. Each individual cell
screaming in terror at what had happened to it.
They had her marching again before she
was fit to move. Her motor controls had
been all over the place. She had fallen
over regularly, and the terror of having
one of the soldiers push the button
again engulfed her with every movement.
And yet, perhaps the most
incredible thing about SCP-001-1
was the fact that if you had asked her if
she should have been held in this kind of
containment, she would immediately
have agreed without batting an eye.
The only person capable of opening the box,
she recognized how dangerous her existence
was. Only she had seen into the mysteries of
the box, only she had seen the horrors laid
inside of it, and so only she could fully
understand the gravity of their situation.
They kept her on the move in order to keep the
world safe. Had she been held in a containment
cell, she would have posed too great a risk. Out
here in the wilderness, the entire planet was
her containment cell—hidden in the middle
of humanity's biggest haystack. No one,
not even the O5 Council’s central command, knew
her location. The only people who were aware
of it at any given time were herself and the
eight soldiers surrounding her with guns drawn.
So you can imagine her horror when, out of
the sheets of rain, appeared the figure of
a person carrying a rifle. The gunfire broke
out before SCP-001-1 even had a chance to hit
the ground. Bullets whizzed through her hair and
cracked open the rocks all around her. The eight
soldiers surrounding her dived for cover as
the figure in the rain slumped to the ground,
lifeless. One of the soldiers grabbed the woman by
her explosive collar and threw her behind a rock.
Clasping her hands over her ears, she closed her
eyes and waited for the fight to be over. No one
was shooting, until a second figure emerged from
the rain waving their arms wildly. Gunfire again.
She wasn't quite sure what had
happened, but all of a sudden,
the woman was falling down the cliff. She
had just been trying to shift her position,
to get deeper into cover, but she clearly hadn't
noticed just how close to the edge she was.
Down and down and down, she fell
until, with a crack in her ankle,
she landed in the peat bog. Gunfire crackled on
the mountain above her, but the only thought that
filled the woman's mind was the terror that at
any moment, the explosive collar around her neck
would be detonated as one of the soldiers
above her realized that she was missing.
Seconds passed as the fear mounted in
her chest. With each passing moment,
the anxiety grew more and more crippling. She
had to know. She had to prepare herself if it
was about to happen. She had to use
the machine and look into the future.
Dragging herself forward through the muck, the
woman snatched at the wooden box. It came alive
at her touch. Different pieces shifted and opened
beneath her fingers like some kind of elaborate
puzzle. No one had taught her how to use this
thing; it just happened. Her fingers would just
dance across its surfaces, pushing and pulling,
opening and closing, twisting and turning, and
locking into place until all of a sudden, there
it was—the box was wide open in front of her.
Taking a deep breath and allowing the rain
to fall on her head for another brief moment,
the woman leaned forward and stepped into the box.
On the trail above her, the gunfire stopped.
Without a word of communication, the soldiers
had deftly flanked the group of people who
had approached them. In less than a minute,
they neutralized each individual
that came their way. In unison,
the group of them walked up to the bodies,
turning them over to examine their faces.
They were nobodies, just a group of hikers lost
in the rain. What had looked like a gun turned
out to be nothing more than a walking pole.
Five of them in total, none of them older
than 24. Without words, the soldiers picked up
the bodies and threw them over their shoulders
as they scrambled their way down the cliffs
to the woman in the machine beneath them.
Once they reached the bottom of the slope, they
discarded the five bodies carelessly into the
bog. Within a couple of hours, those five hikers
would have sunk to the bottom and begun the long
process of being embalmed into the depths. Perhaps
someone would find them in a few thousand years'
time as part of an archaeological dig.
Perhaps, but it was not their concern.
The eight soldiers surrounded the woman,
guns drawn, and stared at her coldly.
“I used the machine,” she told them. “I used it
without your permission. I don't know what the
rules are, I don't know if we even have any
rules here, but I thought you should know.”
The soldiers continued to look at her
in silence. The box was closed now,
sitting back on her lap as it always was.
“I… I tried to see my future. Anytime I've used
the box before, I've looked at the lives of
others. I've seen economic crashes, climate
disasters, genocides, wars, love and life
and death. I've done so at the hands of the O5
Council, done as they've told me, given them the
information, and prevented the destruction of the
world. Never once have I looked at my own future.”
The soldiers lifted her to her feet and tried
to march her onwards, not listening to a word
she was saying. Her broken ankle buckled
and screamed beneath her. She had to hop
to keep up with them. What other choice did she
have? They would push the button if she didn't.
She didn’t know why she kept talking. But she did.
“For the first time… the machine lied
to me. I saw that I was assassinated
in 1987 in Cuba. It was years
before I ever built the box,
before any of this happened to me. I saw
in my future that I no longer existed,
that the Machine no longer existed, but that
future was years ago, and none of it happened.
The machine doesn’t lie. So why is it lying
to me now? Why can’t I see my own future?”
If any of the soldiers were paying
attention, they didn’t show it. They
just continued to march her into the rain,
as the bomb weighed heavily around her neck.
Now check out SCP-001 - The Children - Ouroboros
Cycle and Insane SCP-001 Fight
- Gate Guardian VS Scarlet King!